what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into Supergirl rebirth
this is an interesting scenario in DC
Comics and the reason why I say that is
because from what I've been able to
gather historically speaking anyway a
lot of like the DC movies and shows and
so on have kind of like derive their
content from the comics for example the
flash TV show derives a lot of its stuff
from the comics the new 52 run the
Wonder Woman movie pulled a lot of its
stuff from a combination of like the new
52 Wonder Woman and even you know as so
far as like DC bombshells
in a lot of ways but Supergirl is kind
of a unique situation because Supergirl
really derives a lot of his content from
the show and the sense of like how she's
depicted in how she's done now this is
one of the scenarios were to kind of
work in tandem in order to restore
Supergirl to the legacy that she had
upheld for so long and the reason why I
say that is because of the fact that
Supergirl when she was first introduced
into DC Comics was very much a character
that was part Superman and then
something a little bit more of course
Superman kind of stands on his own two
legs just because of the legacy that he
created so it's one of those things
where it's like Superman is what he is
and there's really no working around
that just kind of how things work with
his character but with Supergirl DC had
to find a way to make her interesting
while simultaneously making sure that
she was her own character and so what
they ended up doing is they actually
ended up kind of having her embody this
example of like a little bit of
innocence you know like one part
innocence one part hope and then one
part just walk power and that's really
what she was when it wanted to like
crisis on Infinite Earths for example
she was like the last member of the
super family that was left to fight the
anti-monitor
and was the only one that could damage
it the problem with this was that going
into the post-crisis landscape Supergirl
in the form of Kara zor-el was gone I
mean she was eliminated and the reason
for that was because of the fact that
after crisis on Infinite Earths DC
wanted to restore the Superman mantle as
Superman basically being the last
survivor of Krypton and with Supergirl
being there it didn't allow for that so
they basically got rid of her then they
just kind of invoked this weird like
cyborg kind of I don't know some weird
situation with Supergirl it was it
wasn't very it wasn't very interesting
but in late 1993 after zero-hour crisis
in time DC brought her back the problem
was that when they rebooted in 2011 with
a new 52 people hated Supergirl because
Supergirl again was supposed to be the
sort of innocent meets power meets hope
kind of character you know kind of this
perfect embodiment of Superman and a
little bit more but she wasn't any of
that she was just like this angsty
teenage girl they're like
no her place in the world no one
understands me you know and all that
kind of nonsense
then people hated it people just didn't
like it at all and so because of that
she was literally just kind of shuffled
around from one story to the next and DC
tried their best to make her interesting
but nothing really worked she routinely
stayed one of their lowest selling
titles and so with DC rebirth what they
did is they went back and they said okay
let's reinvigorate Supergirl you know
she's really popular when it comes to
the show and so we basically wanted to
give people a measure of familiarity and
they can do that with her character you
know especially with the character of
cat grant just because of the fact that
she's not wildly significant by any
standard of measurement but with DC
rebirth the way it's done here or at
least with Supergirl rebirth remember
we've covered this already he knows to
the whole Supergirl rebirth story the
one shot that we were given but of
course following the events of Superman
doomed and all that kind of stuff
the atmosphere was basically sort of
irradiated with you know kryptonite more
or less and what this did is it put you
know Supergirl in a circumstance where
she was on the verge of losing her
powers and so what they did in Supergirl
rebirth is they basically invoked to the
beö the Department of extra-normal
operations and this group goes back to
like 1998 they're not super old but they
have their own little bit of history you
know they have a good chunk of time in
in terms of you know their appearances
and in DC Comics in the role they play
but they basically exist just kind of
like monitor superhero threats around
the world and make sure they don't
become a threat to society at large but
at the same time they also looked at the
idea of Supergirl and said yeah we can
make sure she doesn't become a threat
but she can also be an asset to she's
somebody that we can use for our own
ends I mean it's not like you know the
Suicide Squad under Amanda Waller but it
is the idea that she can basically help
to curb superhero threats because it's
like the de Oh having their own little
Superman and so because of that super
girl's powers were restored by the de oh
but under the idea that she's going to
effectively work for them now again this
all worked out just because of the fact
that she was basically adopted by a
couple agents for the de oh and they
effectively became her parents and they
do the best they can to raise her and
that's really the nature of this in the
sense that cat grants kind of rolled
back in in the traditional landscape
which is to say as she's gone back to
being kind of arrogant you know full of
hubris and things like that because in
the new 52 again she was a little
younger she wasn't necessarily as
arrogant as she is now but this was
really designed to kind of bring her
closer to the TV show counterpart as
opposed to kind of making her own
character now once the TV show starts to
drop off in popularity assuming that it
ever does then what DC will probably do
is they'll probably bring her more back
line with her post-crisis iteration
which means I shall probably have a son
named Adam you know different things
like that they'll bring him back and all
that kind of good stuff up but the fact
remains here this really emphasizes the
idea that Supergirl just doesn't quite
feel at home and that's one of the
reasons why I kind of look at the story
and say this is what the new 52 should
have been because in the new 52 she was
angry at the world because she didn't
have a home you know it wasn't like
Superman where he had lived on earth for
20-some odd years and you know grew
acclimated to earth itself you know and
then eventually became Superman
basically formed a life for himself for
Supergirl she is technically older than
Superman is and so you know while he
arrived on earth as a baby she was just
kind of floating out in space and stasis
before a decade or two so that when she
arrived on earth she was younger than he
was but it's one of those weird
situations but she's not acclimated to
life on her she's not used to it she
hasn't grown up as a little baby with a
family I mean for all intents and
purposes
Superman might as well be human dude the
fact that he was discovered as an infant
and raised by the Kemp's with Supergirl
she showed up here when she was already
you know in her teenage years more or
less and so because of that she's at
that point now where she's trying to
figure out her place in the world she's
trying to understand what she's about
being on a planet that's not her own
complicates those things in addition to
this it's also the idea of rolling in
these agents of the de oh trying to be
her parents and they're kind of stuck in
a situation that they're not normally
used to and again this is designed to
mimic the nature of parents because you
know under normal circumstances people
you know normal human beings they pop
out a kid and there's no guidebook on
how to raise that kid there's no
guidebook on what you're supposed to do
on how you're supposed to take care of
that child not by any standard of
measurement you just take it day by day
and do the best you can much like this
circumstance they're agents they don't
have kids they've never been in a
situation like this you know for them it
initially started out as a job it
started out as a chore you know look
your assignment is to raise this girl
but the longer time went on the more
they started to view her as a daughter
and so because of this they do though
you know the best they can and trying to
get things together but at the end of
the day they still somewhat struggle now
of course this coincides with the idea
of Supergirl basically taking off to the
fortress of solitude just because of the
fact that remember the new 52 Superman
gave her the key to the fortress of
solitude and said this will be your home
away from home if the world becomes too
chaotic if the world becomes too much
for you to bear then this can be a place
where you can come to find some small
measure of peace where you can sort of
let your mind be at ease and try to get
back and touch with some aspect of
Krypton now of course this was kind of
an experience that the new 52 Superman
passing onto her because it's the same
thing he did the classic Superman that
we see now in DC rebirth is the same
thing that he did in the classic
Superman stories so again it works very
well for her the problem with this is
that as soon as she comes back she's met
with cyborg Superman now here's the
funny thing about this this is not Hank
Henshaw cyborg Superman and that's kind
of the weird situation because in the
new 52 DC kind of danced around it right
like Hank Henshaw cyborg Superman was
nowhere to be found
in the new 52 and so when a cyborg
superman popped up in Supergirl stories
as part of the new 52 PC was like well
maybe it's cyborg superman maybe it's
not I mean that's that's the game that
they were playing that's a problem that
they were playing I mean he was never
officially referred to by name it was
just this cyborg Superman now of course
his story unfolded we was basically
learned that he was created by Brainiac
but the problem was that his plot point
was never fully resolved he was just
sort of there and then he fought
Supergirl for a little while and then he
was gone and it was just because of the
fact that DC was literally flying by the
seat of their pants when it came to the
to the Supergirl character now what this
does is it basically wraps that up and
it actually does it pretty well but I
would go as far as to say that this
turns out to be someone who's not Hank
Henshaw just because of the fact of
what's going on in Superman with regards
to you know classic Superman being
restored in DC rebirth sort of coming
back is a chance for DC to kind of beef
up the classic Superman roster General
Zod doomsday the original cyborg
superman hank henshaw the return of the
Eradicator different things like that if
DC is going with that direction then it
makes sense because regardless of what
Supergirl fans will say Superman is the
face of DC Comics I mean that's just the
way it is there's no arguing that that's
just how it goes because of that super
girls have always gonna play second
fiddle she's always going to get you
know more or less the hand-me-downs now
it doesn't mean that you can't have her
own rogues gallery that she can't have
her own stories definitely and this is a
really strong direction and making her
her own character as it should be but it
makes sense that if DC is bringing back
hank henshaw cyborg superman as we know
they are they can't didn't turn around
and throw cyborg superman and Supergirl
stories without fleshing him out in the
Superman stories first so again it's one
of those things that just kind of comes
together and just sort of makes sense
and so again this wraps up this loose
plot thread pretty fast on the other
half of this is building in the idea of
a cat grant you know kind of bringing
her character more into the fold
having her play more of a role
in the life of of Kara zor-el again kind
of established in this idea that cat
grant had spotted Kara zor-el during a
seminar in school really kind of
educator in the idea of hey look if you
want to get ahead in the world you got
to be willing to cut some throats but
it's also this idea of Kara zor-el just
not quite being content not quite being
happy and that's the core of the story
the fact that she just kind of feels out
of place now this is one of the reasons
why the idea of Supergirl always
resonated with her fan base because Kara
zor-el at least the classic heroes
Norrell you really kind of grew with her
as she grew for example she was first
introduced and then she was basically a
backup feature you know in Superman
stories it wasn't until some 10 years
after her original appearance that she
got her own stories with an adventure
comics and even then it wasn't really
called Supergirl it was just adventure
comics and it had Supergirl DC had a
slow bill they took time building her
character up but over that 10-year
window fans grew with Supergirl so that
by the time she got her own solo series
it was tantamount to them being 18 years
old getting out getting their own job
getting her own apartment they basically
kind of stepped into the game of life at
the same time that she did and so
because of that this follows a lot of
the same trend in the sense that she's
still trying to figure out her place in
the world she's trying to understand
where it is that she's going at the same
time she's really sort of told by cyborg
superman look I've recreated Argo city
Argo city exists out there you want to
go home
you do not view earth as your home you
do not view earth as a place that you
belong and so because of this she's
tempted to go investigate things to go
check things out to go see what's going
on and when she arrives she finds Argo
city has been reconstructed by cyborg
Superman of course who declared himself
to be zor-el to be her father and so
again this is kind of cool because what
this does is it basically gives a
purpose and it gives a name to this you
know cyborg superman
to zor-el and so that's kind of the cool
thing here is because it gives her her
own villain her own version of cyborg
superman so to speak you know instead of
this guy just kind of being a faceless
nameless villain that she's facing off
against that may or may not be hank
henshaw depending on how you want to
look at it now he's his own guy
now he's his own villain now he's
supergirls villain and so again this is
building up the Supergirl roster it's
building up the Supergirl landscape is
giving Supergirl fans a reason to say
this is why this character is wholly
your own the other half of this is
really the idea of growing the
coming-of-age story that just because
you want some
doesn't mean they're gonna give it the
way you wanted and that's kind of the
funny thing here is because she's sort
of built up this image in her mind of
what she wants Argo city to be of how
she imagines Argo City coming back that
it's gonna be exactly the way she
remembered it but much like life just
because you remember something a certain
way doesn't mean it was that way and
that's the struggle that Kara zor-el is
dealing with now this manifests itself
not so much literally in the sense that
jor-el has reconstructed Argo city and
used the technology of Brainiac to
reconstruct all the citizens of Argo
City albeit in the form of cyber wars
and the reason why this matters is
because of the fact that Kara's Wells
mother had followed her to Argo city as
part of a joint venture between the two
to basically explore Argo city and to
see what's going on if for no other
reason than the fact that eliza can
basically look around and see what
Supergirl was talking about what she
says she wants to go home she wants to
go back to the way things were you know
kind of makes her a better mom and that
sort of situation problem with this is
that what cyborg Superman has done isn't
going through and recreating kind of
creating these cyborg versions of the
people of Argo city he kind of needs
like a spark of life so to speak if that
makes sense and that's not a new thing
right like I mean that's that's
something that routinely happens and
comic books for example with the
character of like Madeline Pryor back in
the old x-men comics you had Jean Grey
and you had Cyclops eventually Jean Grey
became a Phoenix you know she ultimately
ended up you know sacrificing her life
but while all that was happening the
villain mr. sinister came to the
realization that if Scott Summers and
Jean Grey ever haven't ever had a kid
that kid would effectively be God just
because of all the power that he would
possess and so because he couldn't take
Jean Grey proper he basically cloned her
and so when Jean Grey kind of you know
sacrificed her life as the Phoenix force
so to speak a granted a spark of life in
the body of Madeline Pryor bringing her
to life now of course she was basically
discarded by mr. sinister because she
didn't have any of the powers that Jean
Grey had but the fact remains that's the
kind of thing that we see when we talk
about you know Michelle getting a spark
of life it's really just kind of kicking
the essence of another being and putting
it in somebody else now with what it is
that Zarrella is doing here it's a lot
more literal in the sense that it's not
like oh you know it's just it's the
essence of that person what he's doing
is quite literally draining life away
from people he's starting with Eliza and
kind of taking the the life force of who
she is and throwing that in the body of
supergirls mother now of course what
this does is it basically brings
supergirls mother back or at least it
gives the cyborg version some life but
she's got all the
memories that she had before the problem
with this is that she's just as much a
slave as she is the actual mother of
Supergirl in the sense that she has
programming and it's really difficult
for her to override her program and so
what is up happening here is that we're
super girls taken prisoner by her father
her father immediately launches an
attack on the planet Earth for the
purpose of taking humanity draining the
life force out of them and then putting
that life force in those individuals who
are cyborgs thereby returning our ghost
city back to the way it's supposed to be
now this is kind of interesting and the
reason why is because it'd be very easy
for us to look at the character of
zor-el and say yeah man that guy's a
villain that guy's a bad guy but not
necessarily I mean the guy's doing some
pretty unsavory things but if all we
were looking at was actions to determine
who's a bad guy who's a good guy things
would be vastly different but if we look
at the idea of intention his intention
is just to bring his people back his
intention is to restore his city to the
way that it's supposed to be it almost
falls in line with what it is that
Supergirl wants he's giving her the wish
that she wants that's more than one of
the things that he says is look in the
time that I've been around here I've
heard you talking to yourself I've heard
you talk about how this just isn't your
home how you want Argo city back I've
heard other people talk about you about
how there's something weird about you or
how you're an alien those who know who
you are you know I'm giving you your
heart's desire I'm giving you back Argo
city and it's one of those things where
Supergirl kind of looks at it and says
yeah I'd wanted that but not like this
you know I want our ghost city back the
way I envisioned it not the way that I'm
kind of stuck with and again this is
kind of a reflection of the real world
versus the world that we imagined it to
be it's one of these coming-of-age kind
of things where you basically learn look
not everything is the way that you want
it to be and you just got to learn to
deal with it and so again it's kind of
cool here and the other half of this is
that again this really hits home with
the idea of look super girls gotta win
right like the day's got to be saved I
mean it wouldn't be a superhero story if
she didn't come out on top it's so of
course you know trying to reason with
her mother saying look you know if you
have any memory of who you used to be
and you've got to be able to look around
and your husband look around as well and
realize this is all wrong this is not
the way things are supposed to be and so
ultimately of course her mother
basically betrays our programming at
least for a fraction of a second and
restores life back to Eliza and then
sacrifices herself in the process and so
in doing so one is up happening is Kara
zor-el actually hits up on a homing
signal that's being generated by zor-el
himself and this electro signal is
really more like a frequency like a
radio wave and it's what this
containment cell uses in order to
basically keep
contain and so much like creating a key
to a door she's able to basically break
herself out now of course this results
in kind of like cellular manipulation
with regards to the to the containment
cell in the sense that they're all
basically like you know nano-cells
electrical cells and she's basically
able to tap into their frequency and
then weaken them you know kind of break
them apart and then free herself in the
process but what it does is it gives her
a genius idea because back on earth all
hell is breaking loose now of course
this kind of begs the question why is it
like Superman or the Justice League or
somebody else like that you know getting
involved I couldn't say for any measure
of certainty but to hazard a guess I
would say that if the Justice League got
involved or Superman got involved and
saved the day in the inaugural story of
Supergirl it would immediately diminish
the capabilities of her as a character
and the goal of DC you know with with
regard to the Supergirl title isn't to
make a story called
Supergirl and the people who save her
life its Supergirl so it's just designed
to focus on her and what it is that
she's capable of doing and so she's able
to save the day for the most part in the
sense that she's you know able to fight
off you know against her I'll save a few
people in the process but the genius of
her plan comes into play when she hits
up with cat grant as well as the d EO
and the reason why is because of the
fact that the d EO has a technology that
she needs in order to initiate a signal
that will interfere with the you know
radio signal so to speak that so L is
using to control the various robots that
he has that are going around grabbing
people kidnapping them so on and so
forth but cat grant was a former gossip
columnist and so because of that she has
a lot of connections with regards to
radio stations news companies so on and
so forth and so it would allow her to
actually broadcast the signal as it was
really one of these things that kind of
works in tandem but this is again sort
of building up the community of
Supergirl basically saying look she's
got a lot of resources at her disposal
and it all really comes out to help
benefit her at the end of the day which
of course she's successful in using when
it comes to sending out this signal
disrupting zor-el himself cutting him
off from all the other cyborgs that are
out there and then basically using this
signal to incapacitate him but again if
this were a Superman story I would
daresay he would just beat the absolute
crap out of Zorro and that's kind of
what we would expect is for him to just
fight and fight and fight and fight but
with Supergirl it's a little bit
different you know what she lacks and
strength in comparison to her cousin she
ends up making up for with regards to
her intelligence now this is one of the
other funny things about this because
there is the classic super girl from
before crisis on Infinite Earths
and there's a Supergirl as we see here
in truth we haven't really
like an actual drag down lockout fight
between the DC rebirths Supergirl and
the DC rebirth Superman and so we don't
really know exactly how they compare in
strength because again this is not the
new 52 Superman this is the classic
Superman that we have in DC rebirth
right now and so because of that if we
were to take for example the pre-crisis
on Infinite Earths Supergirl she'd beat
the absolute crap out of DC Reber
Superman she would totally recommend one
of the craziest things is she's a lot
stronger than he is well maybe not a lot
stronger but she's definitely stronger
than he is with this version of
Supergirl we don't really know what a DC
possibly beefed up her strength when she
got her powers back because that's that
really kind of begs the question I mean
I would go as far as to say that before
she lost her powers in the new 52 she
probably wouldn't stand a chance against
classic Superman but with her powers
being restored by the de Oh does that
offer DC the opportunity to come back
and say well when she got her powers
back they were amplified to some level
that we weren't aware of before and now
she's stronger than she was when she
first popped up in the new 52 so again
it offers a lot of different
possibilities in terms of what direction
she can go in and what she's capable of
but at the end of the day you know with
her basically defeating cyborg superman
she's forced to realize that there is no
going home you know there's no way for
her to go back that she basically is
stuck on earth and she's gonna have to
get used to being here the cool thing
about this is that again this is sort of
her just reconciling where she is and
what's going on right now again she's
trying to figure out where she is where
she's going all that kind of good stuff
another thing to point out here is that
following the defeat of zor-el cyborg
superman and argo city basically
crashing down into the ocean what this
does is it leads to hank henshaw being
granted the ability to go and
investigate the argo city wreck and so
that's why this is important is because
what this does is it will allow hank
henshaw presumably to discover this
cybernetic are against the cyborg
technology the technology of Brainiac
that was used by jor-el which in turn
which transform him into cyborg superman
which would lead directly into the
Superman reborn aftermath revenge story
then ends up seeing you know basically
all of Superman's most notable villains
re-emerging and facing off against him
but again a pretty good story I mean I
really enjoyed this it was a pretty
solid story for the inaugural DC
rebirths Supergirl Lana me definitely
has a lot of similarities with the show
which is not a bad thing because the
show is actually pretty good so I'm I
kind of like the direction that they're
going I hope they bolster her powers so
she comes closer to the pre-crisis on
Infinite Earths
super
again she's a lot more prominent a lot
more capable and a lot stronger than she
initially lets on but in the end only
time will tell
so without being said guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]